[Music]
welcome to Bible answers live where
you'll get honest answers to your Bible
questions let's face it it's not always
easy to understand everything you read
in the Bible with 66 books and more than
700 thousand words the Bible can
generate a lot of questions if you'd
like answers to your Bible questions
you've come to the right place now
here's your host pastor Doug Batchelor
president and speaker of amazing facts
hello listening friends would you like
to hear an amazing fact back in 1999 a
small black and white kitten appeared in
the backyard of Wallace and Ann Toledo
the elderly couple believed that someone
had thrown the unwanted kitten over the
fence into their mobile home park and
they were worried about its welfare that
was until they noticed the kids unlikely
care taker an American crow day after
day the kalidahs watched in amazement as
the crow took care of the kitten who
they named Cassie under its wings it
began feeding it worms and insects they
couldn't believe their eyes as they
watched the crow they had dubbed Moses
feeding Cassie and protecting her from
other animals Moses would claw and fat
and flap wildly to keep her out of the
street they knew no one would believe
the remarkable tale unless they had
proof so over a period of five years
they began filming and photographing the
kitten playing with its watchful winged
Guardian friend you know the Bible says
that God has used crows before to even
care for people stay with us we're gonna
learn more on this edition of Bible
answers live
[Music]
you're listening to Bible answers live
honest answers to your Bible questions
our phone lines are now open if you have
a Bible related question call us at one
eight hundred
one eight hundred four sixty three
seventy to ninety seven now let's join
our host pastor Doug Batchelor and our
co-host pastors Jean Ross
welcome listening friends to Bible
answers live and as the title suggests
if you have a Bible question we're live
we welcome you to call in with your
questions plenty of phones open right
now and the number is 800
sets eight hundred four six three seven
two nine seven we know there's a lot of
people that are out on the road tonight
traveling returning home after the
holidays that maybe haven't heard the
program before we'd invite you to call
in with your questions we'll get
priority to first-time callers and again
the number free phone call Bible
questions eight hundred four six three
seven two ninety seven my name is Doug
Batchelor my name is John Ross good
evening listening friends and pastor
Doug as always let's start the program
with the word of Prayer your Father in
Heaven we thank you for the opportunity
that we have to study your word together
tonight as we open up the Bible we do
pray for the Holy Spirit to guide our
hearts our minds be those listening
wherever they might be for we ask this
in Jesus name Amen
amen pastor you opened the program but
talking about a crow that showed
remarkable concern for a kitten now of
course cats have a history of eating
birds ant things seem to be the other
way around the bird is providing food
for this little kitten which eventually
became a cat because you mentioning the
fact that this had gone on for several
months several years actually yes yes
and eventually I think after five years
of recording one day Moses The Crow did
not show up and you know they didn't
know something happened but the the
kitten was you know adopted by the
family and he's still alive today when I
last read up on this but you know it
didn't really surprise me for a couple
of reasons the Bible talks about Ravens
that took care of one of God's prophets
now Ravens crows are all in what they
call the corvid family which is a group
of birds that are among the most
intelligent not just birds most
intelligent creatures in fact scientists
believe that the intelligence of
Ravens and crows is right up there next
to apes and they have the largest brain
capacity of any bird for for its size so
they're very intelligent they use tools
they learn quickly they're one of the
few animals that they say they've
spotted crows in England where one will
hold up a garbage can lid for the others
to eat and then take turns while the
others hold it up almost no animals show
that kind of sharing capacity well you
know making an intelligent sacrifice
saying now it's my turn you hold the can
open an ollie so they're very very smart
creatures but they're listed in the
Bible as unclean as far as food but God
used crows to bring food to one of their
prophets that was hungry now you read
this interesting story in 1st Kings 17
verse 2 then the word of the Lord came
to him to Elisha saying get away from
here and turn eastward and hide by the
brook Cherith which flows into the
Jordan and it will be that you'll drink
from the brook and I have commanded the
Ravens to feed you there so he went and
did according to the word of the Lord
and he went and he stayed by the brook
Cherith which flows by the Jordan and
the Ravens brought him bread and food in
the morning and bread and meat in the
evening and he drank from the brook and
for a period of months evidently God had
these Ravens just twice a day feeding
him with food that they'd collected
somewhere else now this has been
observed many times Ravens grabbing food
and flying off with it and I think he
said one time you had a seagull stole
some of your food yeah just before I had
a chance to bite down the seagull came
had the same it's right out of my end
and yeah the Ravens will do that so
somewhere they were they were sniping
food and bringing it to Elijah and of
course Noah he even used a raven that
must have been somewhat tame to go and
see if the waters had
you know going off the earth and so it
basically reminds us of a couple of
things God's provision and the
incredible
inter acting
symbiotic relationships in God's
creation you know as we look in the
world around us you just see the
intelligence of these creatures and you
start to realize how this isn't
something that evolved accidentally that
God has built something into his
creation that can be seen and we've got
a free offer tonight that I think will
inspire you with God's power and his
creative ability why don't you tell us
about that pastor yes it's a book that
amazing facts has entitled amazing
wonders of creation and yes it is
amazing talking about these incredible
creatures that God has made I'll be
happy to send this book to anybody who
calls and asks again it's called amazing
wonders of creation that is the free
offer this evening to receive it call us
on our resource phone line that's 883
five six seven four seven and you can
ask for the book called amazing wonders
of creation the number one more time is
eight hundred eight three five six seven
four seven and if you have a Bible
question our phone line here to the
studio is 800 four six three seven two
nine seven and we do have phone lines
open it's good time to pick up your
phone give us a call we'll get your
Bible question on the air this evening
it's 800 four six three seven two nine
seven will mention that number several
times throughout the program ready to go
to our first caller this evening let's
see we have Gabby no listening from
Texas Gavino welcome to the program
thank you thanks for calling your
question
yes I
just
experienced the death of my aunt my
beloved
use of surreal experience as I saw the
best mmm life leave her body and it
seemed like I seemed like her head
vibrated as her head their spirit laps
mmm my question is you say that the
breath of life goes back to God and you
say the spirit goes to sleep
well actually okay all right go ahead
I'm sorry finish your question I'm
confused ish is the breath of life
that was personally hers is it with
always here on the earth well let's just
if it's based on a verse that you find
in Ecclesiastes chapter 12 it tells us
that when a creature dies not just a
human and it's not even saying the good
or the bad it doesn't say just the good
or just the bad it just says when
someone dies that the the body returns
to the earth you know God told Adam Ash
as you are and into ashes you'll return
so the body of everybody that dies we
know what happens it decomposes and even
those who are saved they get new
resurrected bodies Paul says and it says
the spirit and that word there in Hebrew
is rowlock and the verse by the way is
clean acid chapter 12 verse 7 yeah the
breath of life that's what the word
Spirit means returns to God who gave it
so this passage is not talking about the
soul or the essence of who the person is
it's just simply saying that the power
of life returns to God the body returns
to the dust that's all Solomon is saying
there so you're asking where is the
essence of who that person is
you know there's something when we start
to talk about a person's the soul of who
they are and where I'm using that word
kind of in the classic sense
we do something every day with computers
that kind of gives you a crude idea I
might have all kinds of things that I've
written books and documents and all this
personal information and I put it on a
jump drive and I pull it out of the
computer and they can sit on that drunk
drive for a hundred years and it doesn't
do anything until I plug it back into
the computer
and so God has stored or saved and we
talked about cloud services God has
stored or backed up whoever your aunt is
or all of his loved ones that have
passed away he knows who they are he's
got the the info on who they are at the
resurrection they are placed within the
Nuba he gives they come to life and it's
like at the beginning it says God
breathed into Adam the breath of life
God made Adams form but he wasn't alive
yet his body was there it's all perfect
but he's dead but God breathes into him
the breath of life in Adam became a
living soul you know in the Bible we
also see death Illustrated his asleep
and in one way when a person goes to
sleep especially if they sleeping a deep
sleep without dreams they are
unconscious of their surroundings and
yet when they wake up in the morning
it's the same person that went to sleep
the night before so likewise the dead in
Christ when they breathe their last
breath and they are dead they in that
unconscious sleep as the Bible describes
it when Jesus comes again and there is
the resurrection it's the same person
coming up from the grave but with a
glorified body how exactly their works
well the bible does call it a mystery
yeah Paul talks about the mystery of the
resurrection yeah for them it doesn't
seem like you know let's say it's 10
years until the Lord comes we don't know
for your aunt whenever you believer dies
for them it's instantaneous their next
conscious thought is the resurrection
because it's you know if you have a
rough night and you don't sleep well you
know it's been a long night but if you
sleep well it seems like a moment right
so
for believers their next conscious
thought is absent from the body is the
resurrection in the presence of the Lord
my next question she wasn't
she wasn't a biblical she's a possible I
will tell her before he close your eyes
please ask Jesus Christ for forgiveness
and he'll give you a new body the next
time you wake up and of course after she
passed away uh nurse came up to me
I spoke to your aunt about salvation and
she told me yes she would accept and I'm
hoping Wow that I got offered a person
yes she will be awakened with a party
party and she of course he's a the face
of God yeah well you know that's our
prayer first of all good news and that
gives you hope and the Bible says that
we
we're treasuring those blessed hope that
blessed hope that the Lord gives us and
that we don't sorrow as others that do
not have hope and that's first
Corinthians I'm sorry first
Thessalonians chapter 4 so we do have a
special offer I think you'll find some
encouragement in Gavin and it's a book
it's a study guide that will send you
that's got all the scriptures on the
subject of death and how you can have
hope and encouragement the study guide
is called all the dead really dead I'll
be happy to send it to anybody who calls
and ask the resource phone line is 883
five six seven four seven and again you
can ask for the study guide called odd
the dead really dead we also have a
website called death truth common and go
to it right away and you can actually
read this lesson right there online
along with a lot of other scriptural
references there are actually sermons
available so just a great study resource
again that website is called death truth
com our next caller that we have is Alan
listening from Ohio Alan welcome to the
program
hi any thanks for going question is yeah
alright my question is is about the
virgin birth of Jesus Christ and first
I'd like to outline a hypothetical
situation suppose a man gets married to
a woman who's a virgin and they have yet
to have any sexual intercourse then a
second man comes along and as
sexual intercourse with the woman and
it's consensual and the woman becomes
pregnant wouldn't that be adultery and
on the part of the second man and the
the woman are you wondering if because
Joseph and Mary were engaged for her to
be artificially inseminated by the Holy
Spirit would be as though God was
breaking his own law
I didn't know they were just engaged I
thought they were married but then they
became married later anyway weren't they
yeah well you remember it says in the
Bible that he was they were engaged to
be married the wedding hadn't happened
yet because it says before they came
together obviously after persons been
fully married they almost immediately
consummated the marriage before Joseph
and Mary came together she was found to
be with child so the marriage had not
happened yet but nonetheless is I guess
you're saying that you know here a human
man did it was involved instead of the
Holy Spirit wouldn't there be adultery
well let me ask you let me put the
question to you a different way and I
appreciate your question
let's suppose that a man and woman are
engaged and
they cannot have children and
the woman says well if I could be
inseminated somehow if we could get
medical help to take your sperm connect
it with my egg implanted in me and we'll
have a baby there'd be nothing wrong
with that right
did you understand my question
so I'm saying that let's what the Bible
tells us is that she was found to be
with child of the Holy Spirit that she
was conceived of by the Holy Spirit it
doesn't say there was nothing of Joseph
that was in Mary matter of fact it goes
through greatly oh no of course not see
I said before the first man and the
virgin woman had any special I know but
so what is your concern that God somehow
was doing something wrong by
it Lady Mary yeah it seems like it so
who made man in the beginning
well of course God so what would be
wrong with God saying you know I'm the
author of life I'm going to give you a
child that is going to actually have
part of me in it the savior of the world
and you know joseon that I mean there
were no complaints from Joseph and I
don't think Joseph were jealous
so they here the privilege of raising
the son of God
yeah
any thoughts on this pastor Russell well
you know I think the illustration use is
good
you wouldn't classify it adultery if a
spouse can't have a child for some
reason and they talk about it and an egg
is donated or whatever sperm is donated
and you know you wouldn't call it
adultery well in this case that doesn't
fly tit I don't think that Virgin Mary
isn't it true that she wasn't like
Sarah who couldn't have children does it
say in the gospel that the Virgin Mary
could not have children like no era
Sarah was a number of the Hebrew women
were barren it's interesting actually
about seven of them were the virgin mary
was bare no no she was probably
extremely firm is different it's
different yeah well what you have the
the similarity between Sarah and Mary is
that they were both miraculous for Sarah
at ninety years old to get pregnant
after she's already gone through
menopause was miraculous and of course
for Harry
yeah
but
are you wondering why God you know ya
know I'm wondering that why wouldn't it
be adultery if a human did that well
that's the key right there it wasn't a
human
it was the author of all life well you
have to admit that every life is a
miracle and so whenever anybody has a
baby it's a gift of God children are the
heritage of the Lord the Bible says and
it's a God that blesses the fruit of the
womb and so if God told Mary in advance
look I'm going to actually show you that
this child is special in the very way
that the whole conception takes place
so
they have the Holy Spirit involved in
that is you know just a wonderful
miraculous thing I don't think anybody
thought that Oh God cheated on Joseph so
but I understand it's a valid question I
could see where if it was a man yeah but
it was the Holy Spirit was gone creating
giving him a gift every Jewish mother
wished she could have the Messiah hey I
appreciate your question thank you very
much Alan and I
think we have anything special
we do have a website called Mary truth
com there you go that talks a little bit
about this miraculous birth and I think
you'd find that interesting just type in
a Mary truth com if you have a Bible
question a phone line here to the studio
is eight hundred four six three seven
two nine seven that's eight hundred four
sixty three seventy to ninety seven with
your Bible question next quality is at
Katharine listening in Illinois
Katharine welcome to the program
hi all right thanks for calling I
my question is about Genesis 813 I
was reading trying to understand
why everyone thinks
that Noah didn't
tear the ark apart and with it make a
Noah town with the ark or the remnants
of the ark and then I noticed in
Genesis 813 that it said he was on the
ark for 600 for 601
years no it's in the 600 first year of
Noah's life
yeah it's not that he was on the ark 600
years I'd be a long cruise yeah
okay so but your second question was
could they have used the ark as you know
many times captains have landed and the
ship was damaged and they basically
disassemble everything good out of the
ship it's like the story Pitcairn they
took the bounty and they kind of tore
apart whatever they could use and use
the pieces to construct stuff on the
island they burned the rest
understanding there was nothing right
well after the flood most of the raw
materials were probably in pretty bad
shape after the whole world had been
waterlogged for months so I have no
problem believing that they had taken
some parts of the ark maybe and used
them in construction
but I don't think they stayed in the
area of Ararat for very long because
right after the flood they were up high
in the mountains they probably went down
into the valley for more temperate
climate they may have taken some of the
materials or things down the hill the
Bible doesn't say so we could speculate
and I don't see any reason to think they
didn't use anything
other than it would be try to quite a
trek if they're carrying the beams down
to them valleys you
know it does tell us Noah planted a
vineyard and at the very high altitudes
it vineyard want to do good so he
probably moved down the hill more
temperate climate
okay good question never had that one
before and thank you very much Katherine
bye bye if you have a Bible question our
phone line is eight hundred four six
three seven two nine seven we do have
some lines open good time to give us a
call 800 four six three seven two nine
seven fanox holy is Danny listening in
Tennessee Danny welcome to the program
thank you Pastor Ross and pastor Doug I
enjoy your show ever so much thank you
so much for calling
it's not much it's in uh it's in John I
go to second
John's five in 28 and 29 okay and it
says heard at all the graves you might
you want to read that John chapter five
verse 20 and 29
do not marvel at this Jesus speaking for
the iris coming in which all who are in
their graves will hear his voice and
come forth those have done good to the
resurrection of life those have done
evil to the resurrection of condemnation
okay I was I was comparing that to
Thessalonians 4 and 16 that kind of had
me messed up a little bit it says for
the Lord himself shall descend from
heaven with a shout and with the voice
of an archangel and with the Trump of
God and the dead in Christ shall rise
first
so when it says when Jesus said all that
are in the graves will come forth the
good and the bad and then the first
Thessalonians says the dead in Christ
rise first
you'll notice that both John 5 and first
Thessalonians 4 lists the good first see
see Jesus said all that are in the
graves will hear his voice and come
forth they that have done good the
resurrection of life now notice when you
get two resurrections one is called the
resurrection of life that's the first
resurrection those that have done evil
they come later the resurrection of
condemnation but Jesus even mentions in
both passages there are two different
resurrections
and the author of John
also writes another book called
revelation and if you go to John a
revelation chapter 20 he talks about two
resurrections there
yeah so he says you know blessed and
holy is he that has part in the first
resurrection
then he says the rest of the dead so if
the dead in Christ rise first the rest
of the dead are the wicked the rest of
the dead they come forth at the end of
the one thousand years okay okay so
you're that's very perceptive though
there you're right there are two
resurrections and Jesus just mentions
both resurrections together in chapter 5
but he doesn't say they happened
together he separates them in his
sentence yeah I see where the good is at
the first as I shall come first yeah
yes
okay you know we do a study guide
dealing with the thousand years which
begins with the resurrection of the
righteous and aims at the resurrection
of the wicked and we'll be happy to send
this to you for free Danny or anybody
wanting to learn more about this it's
called a thousand years of peace and
talks about Revelation chapter 20 and
the number to call for that is eight
hundred eight three five six seven four
seven you can ask for the study guide
called a thousand years of peace and of
course if you have a Bible question our
phone line here to the studio is eight
hundred four six three seven two nine
seven that's 800 four 63 72
97 a lot of lines open yeah the people
recovering from their turkey coma or
something so if you want to give us a
call at get good chance of getting your
question on tonight's program if you
ever had a question about the Bible or
living the Christian life that's puzzled
you we don't claim to have all the
answers but we will do our best with
what we know and the Bible resources at
our fingertips free phone call 800 God
says that's eight hundred four six three
seven two nine seven you could say four
six three seventy to ninety seven also
give us a call all right who's up next
fast well we can start on our next
question and then after the break we'll
maybe take the second half of it we got
Jay Jay listening in Kentucky Jay Jay
welcome to the program you're on the air
hi I just appreciate all that y'all do
with the ministry here and I had a
question in regard to Daniel chapter 7
verses 7 through 8 here Daniel's talking
about a dream with the four beasts and
in reference to the fourth beast he
mentions that it has ten horns
and I was just curious what those ten
horns are referring to what they might
correspond to
yeah I tell you what pastor Ross just
finished a seminar on Daniel I'll let
him answer that question you can hear
from the elevator music in the
background we're getting ready to have
just a brief break for station
identification
but hey friends we do have lines open if
you have a question go ahead give us a
call great chance to get your question
on the air tonight here's a number again
800 4 6 3 7 2 97 with your Bible
questions any question about living the
Christian life we love to talk about the
Word of God 804 6 3 7 2 97 we will be
right back
stay tuned Bible answers live we'll
return in a moment
amazing facts began in 1965 with a God
inspired concept hello this is Joe Cruz
on the amazing facts broadcast facts
which affect you each radio broadcast
would begin with an amazing fact from
science nature or history followed by a
Bible message that touched the hearts of
listeners from every walk of life the
program was an instant success and the
ministry soon began expanding to include
Bible lessons in 1986 amazing facts
added the medium of television to its
growing outreach efforts offering
soul-winning evangelistic messages for
viewers around the world in 1994 pastor
Doug Batchelor assumed leadership of the
ministry adding the Bible answers live
call-in radio program and new ministry
TV programs began airing on multiple
networks around the world for 50 years
the driving vision of amazing facts has
been the bold proclamation of the
everlasting gospel and with a team of
evangelists circling the globe and
thousands of men and women being trained
through the amazing fact center of
evangelism program Affco the ministry is
helping God's church see a rich harvest
of souls
amazing facts God's message our mission
[Music]
every bible question you have answered
moves you one step closer to the
fullness of God's will for your life so
what are you waiting for get the answers
you need for a fuller richer more
confident life you're listening to Bible
answers live
we still have a few phone lines open if
you have a Bible related question call
us at one eight hundred seven
eight hundred four six three seven two
nine seven now let's join pastors doug
batchelor and john ross for more Bible
answers live
welcome back listening friends to Bible
answers live and if you have a Bible
question lines are wide open give us a
call we have one or two people standing
by but about seven lines open right now
all you've got to do is make that free
phone call with your Bible questions
804 637 297 I don't almost sounds like
I'm begging we don't want to beg I just
I think people want to talk about the
Word of God they think well we'll never
get on here they're on all over the
country we're on satellite radio all the
lines are all backed up no they're not
give us a call I have a question and
we'll be happy to answer my name is Doug
Batchelor my name is John Ross and just
before the break we were talking to Jay
Jay in Kentucky and JJ you still there
yes sir yes thanks for holding you had a
question about the 10 homes of Daniel
chapter 7
yes sir I was mentioning here in verse 8
that there were 10 horns on the fourth
beast and then that another horn came up
after them and then I was also looking
ahead I in verse 24 it was mentioning
that the ten horns
were ten
teams that would arise out of the fourth
beast I was just curious with those ten
horns might correspond to if we hadn't
any idea
well yes we do actually good question to
help identify who the horns are you're
gonna have to look first of all at the
Beast and you have Daniel chapter 7 a
series of beasts which parallel Daniel
chapter 2 we have different kingdoms so
Babylon was ruling when Daniel wrote The
Book of Daniel followed by me to Persia
that conquered Babylon and then you had
the kingdom of Greece with Alexander the
Great that kingdom was eventually
conquered by Rome and Rome is this
fourth beast but Rome was not conquered
by one other power but rather its
territory was divided up amongst the ten
Germanic invading tribes that came down
from North Eastern Europe and sort of
carved up the territory that was Rome's
territory and became the modern nations
of Western Europe the Franks ended up
settling in France the anglo-saxons in
England and so on and so forth there
were three tribes the Ostrogoths the
Vandals and the hare alai which were
completely uprooted and destroyed and we
have no modern nations of Western Europe
that can trace directly back to one of
those three tribes and then of course
Daniel 7 does talk about a little Horner
rising amongst these ten horns these
horns represent kingdoms and that really
is the introduction of the papal power
that ruled for twelve hundred and sixty
years in Europe from 538 all the way
through to 1798 so that's just a quick
overview of what we see in Daniel 7 with
reference to those horns Oh
fantastic and I'm definitely into Roman
greco history here and said this just
getting specifics on each of those 10
tribes and so forth it's uh yeah I'm
gonna look into more of that and I also
had another question if you don't mind
that you know lines been open um Genesis
chapter 6 referred to the Nephilim and I
was just curious what exactly they were
he's talking about where it says the
sons of God married the daughters of men
yes and then after that in Genesis 6:4
I think referring to them being mighty
men in the earth and just curious I
guess about that whole passage what well
yeah the word Nephilim is great ones
they're Giants and
just so everyone kind of gets the
background what of what's happening here
because this is a verse that is much
discussed misunderstood matter of fact I
wrote a booklet on it that will send you
a free copy of
after Cain killed Abel
Cain took his wife one of his sisters
and he went eastward and he built a city
and he turned his back on God and the
worship of God and all of his
descendants remained separate from Adam
and Eve and there are other children
they had another boy named Seth they had
other sons and daughters you read in
Genesis 5 and as long as they remained
separate and for hundreds of years they
probably remained separate they
continued to worship Jehovah they were
told not to intermarry were the
descendants of Cain that had turned
their back on God and so what happened
is the sons of God the children of Seth
and that were faithful they saw the
daughters of Cain that they were
beautiful and they began to intermarry
and as a result it's something called
genetic vitality they ended up having
these children that were giants that
were just very healthy very big and
it doesn't mean they were part alien or
part demon I've heard all kinds of
strange theories there were giants even
in the time of Abraham and David and
Moses it talks about giants in the land
and we have Giants in the world today
not that many but there they're out
there and so
but there was a whole there's a whole
race of them back then that's the Nephi
em there they're not part angel' they're
not part
you know demon or alien I've heard very
interesting things but yeah just the
descendants of Cain began to intermarry
the descendants of Seth and it says
you're not supposed to have believers
marry with unbelievers the result was
right after it says this God saw the
wickedness of man was great in the earth
that's verse 5 through the intermarriage
they lost their distinctive faithfulness
sin took over violence filled the earth
and God said I'm going to destroy the
world with a flood now we have a booklet
on that we'll be happy to give you a
free copy if you'd like that
and it's called um who are the sons of
God
well thank you yeah definitely preach
all the help all right yeah just for
calling JJ you know one of the quick
thing pass today we're talking a little
bit earlier about Daniel chapter 7 just
before the program you sent me an email
of some Greek coins that one oh yeah it
has the inscription of Alexander the
Great it's got his picture on there in
Daniel chapter 11 you have different
empires represented by different beasts
RAM and then he goat
Daniel 8 sorry Daniel 8 you have these
different beasts
he was showing me on the coin there that
was on earth you have this picture of
Alexander the Great and there are what
looks like ram's horns depicted coming
out of his head so even back in those
days they recognized that beasts would
represent powers and they also recognize
that horns in Bible prophecy represent
Kings kind of interesting that's right
and yeah and the the ten horns and the
beast in Revelation chapter 13 coincide
with the ten toes and the and the ten
powers and Daniel hey Thank You JJ for
your question and that does open a line
if you have a Bible question one more
time 800 for six three seven two 97
brings you to the studio next Coley's
Denise listening in Rhode Island Denise
welcome to the program
hi thank you so much for taking my call
and I appreciate your ministries so much
my question is I was driving home from
work today and I felt like the Holy
Spirit was missing with me and then I
said to myself well I have angels with
me too so is God sending the Holy Spirit
for my mind's protection and the angels
for my physical protection or it just it
just kind of struck me as odd that I
needed both so I didn't know what you
thought about that and I just well just
listen
so your does God send angels for your
protection or for the protection of the
Holy Spirit within you no no no so the I
know I felt like Holy Spirit was with me
but then I said oh I've got angels too
so I guess I must need both I need extra
protection I don't know well the Spirit
works through the Angels yeah that's a
good question the Holy Spirit works
through angels and
the Bible tells us the angel of the lord
encamps roundabout those that fear him
and he delivers them and then you can
read in Psalm 91 he will give his angels
charge over you to keep you in all your
ways and they will bear you up in your
hands lest you dash your foot against a
stone and you can see where the angel of
the Lord came and let the Apostles out
of prison and
angels came and delivered Paul angel
came to Paul on a storm and said
over actually Paul said an angel Lord
stood beside me tonight and so all
through the Bible you see angels that
God uses to protect the Holy Spirit is
in angels like the Holy Spirit's in US
and so God's Spirit may be guarding us
but he still operates through his
ministering spirits has created agencies
that was the verse is gonna reference in
2nd Corinthians chapter 3 verse 7 where
angels are referred to as ministering
spirits saying from God for the purpose
of ministering to us
so the Holy Spirit often uses the angels
to speak to us you've probably seen
these old cartoons where you've got a
person struggling with temptation that
looks like he's getting a good little
angel yeah yeah there's more truth to
that I mean I don't think we've got
little cherubs on our shoulders but
there's more truth to the concept that
there are you know people get tempted by
the devil and his angels and we are
delivered and guided by God's good
angels so there is some truth to that
but hey we appreciate that you know we
do have a study guide that you'd enjoy
it's called angel messages from space
the number to call is eight hundred
eight three five six seven four seven
that is our resource phone line and you
can ask for the study guide called angel
messages from space 808 three five six
seven four seven if you have a Bible
question our phone line here to the
studio is 800 four six three seven two
nine seven eight hundred four 63 72 97 I
Mexico Lee is that David listening in
Sacramento hi David welcome to the
program hey guys how are you doing doing
good thank you for calling
good good I had a question for you guys
but the Bible talks about clean and
unclean eat to eat but it also talks
about the finds the swine's flesh sure
it's not even clean touches that correct
it does say that
okay so if I have clothing let's say
that's made up I don't know take the
belt or tissues or something would that
be wrong to wear well I wouldn't enjoy
knowing that I was wearing
pigskin but I think that can't occurs
from what's the football used to be
called a pigskin because I think it was
made out of the the pigskin
and you know I'm gonna probably shake a
lot of people up right now but there are
actually a number of leather Bibles out
there and it doesn't tell you what the
leather is but we found out at amazing
facts months that a lot of Bibles there
they use Pig leather because it's very
tough and it's inexpensive so it just
seems like a little bit of a paradox to
have pink leather on a Bible
so you know here when is Bible says
you're not to touch their carcass of
course it doesn't just say don't touch
anything from the pig it says don't
touch their carcass
obviously a decomposing carcass can be
you know bare contagious diseases and a
number of plagues have been caused
because of that certainly we're not
supposed to be ingesting the foods that
God declared to be an abomination and
you know Muslims they read the same
passages and
they're they feel very strongly develop
Muslims about not coming near anything
that is connected with a pig
now okay yeah I don't want to belabor
this but I know I'm gonna probably wig
out some people most soap that people
buy if you just buy your soap on the
shelf and it says in the ingredients
Tala weight or sodium tala wait
whenever you see the word tallow that's
often made from fat and they are not
particular about whether it's cow fat or
pig fat but what happens though is by
the time it gets to be soap it has gone
through such a chemical purging and
separation that you're really dealing
with basic elements at that point
so I don't worry about if I grab the
hotel soap what it came from
anyway I don't know if I helped her made
it more confusing David
no you gotta help there are state
brushes that are made of horsehair would
that be wrong and no I don't think so
you know that stuff has been purified if
your person uses a boars hairbrush to
put on their safe shaving cream I don't
think you're going to be rendered
unclean I think you know Jesus said it's
not what goes in your mouth that defiles
you and what I there of course he's
talking about eating with unwashed hands
but certainly if you're just touching
the
the the scrubbed and washed hairs of a
pig I don't think it's gonna render you
unclean you know we do have a study
guide that deals with the subject of at
least eating unclean things what does
the Bible say is good to eat I'll be
able to send you this study guide called
God's free health client anybody who is
listening if you'd like to receive that
just call 883 five six seven four seven
and we'll send you the study guide
called God's free health plan one more
time that number is 885 six seven four
seven and the phone line here to the
studio with your Bible question is 800
four six three seven two nine seven
eight hundred four sixty three seventy
to ninety seven a next caller is Liz
listening from Maryland less welcome to
the program
hi good evening thanks for calling
yes my question is if we were supposed
to tithe from our net income or our
gross income all right that's a good
question now tithe biblically a person
was to take a tenth of their increase
and they would set it aside and Sam
returning that to God in his servus
do you wait until you get your your net
income which means after the
government's gone through and taken out
taxes and Social Security or health
benefits and and number of things might
be deducted before you get your paycheck
so you just pay on what you get or do
you pay on the gross well let's think
about that
the principle of tithe is that when
you've received income for your work and
you've got increase from it by whatever
means you've gained you pay tithe on
that now my understanding is because the
government might take out a percentage
for taxes that's still a benefit for you
because you know that's paying for the
roads we drive on that's pain for the
you know garbage pickup or whatever it
is that the taxes are paying for
that's an expense just like your
groceries it's one of the expenses of
life is you need to pay your rent you
need to pay for groceries you need to
pay your electric bill and you need to
pay for the roads the difference is that
the government takes it out of your
check they don't just send you a bill
but it's still just a regular living
expense see what I'm saying
now the difference would be if they take
out Social Security that's money they're
gonna send you later when you retire
so you can either pay the tithe on your
Social Security when you get old and you
finally start getting the checks back
or if you pay tithe on your income you
pay tithe on your gross then when you
finally get your Social Security check
you've already paid tithe on it you see
what I'm saying yes
that so when we get our income tax
return do we have to type on that or no
well if you've been paying tithe on your
gross no you don't because you've
already paid tithes on that income the
government does ran it through their
books so they're just giving you back
money you already earned it's your money
and you've already paid tithes on it
when you paid on your gross income if
you only paid on the net that you took
home then if you get a tax return you
should be tithe on that you know but let
me I really think that tithe is sort of
like kindergarten for a New Testament
Christian tithe was what God gave his
people in the Old Testament
when we fall in love with the Lord and
we give him a hundred percent of our
hearts you look in the New Testament and
they were saying no man said that ought
that he had was his own but people were
selling houses and lands and giving them
to the preaching of the gospel you you
don't see less
sacrifice in the New Testament you see
more and so tithe is a starting point
something I've discovered is you can't
outgive God I've never experienced loss
because I responsibly gave to God's work
now there are and you don't ever hear us
doing this on this program but there are
some
bamboozling pastors and televangelists
out there we all know about that all
they do is they beg for money and they
say if you send money you're gonna be
healthy wealthy and wise and just send
it to me and they rob people and they
built people and I think Christians need
to be responsible about their giving
that they know they're giving it to a
reputable denomination that preaches the
word that is doing a mission work they
need to support their local church with
their offerings
but when you're faithful and you're
giving God says all open the windows of
heaven for you and pour out a blessing
so you don't have room enough to receive
it so if you accidentally give a little
too much and you're doing it from your
heart God knows how to compensate
does that make sense
yeah he'll yeah I can just tell over and
over through my life that when we
stepped out in faith and we gave a
little extra God some surprises us with
what he does for us it may be
financially or it might be that some
expense we thought we were going to have
we didn't have there's a lot of ways
that God can bless you
we have a study guide we'll send you a
study guide we've got that goes into
detail on this and it's really it's fun
to read it's believe it or not it's
Illustrated and got a lot of scriptures
in it
study guide it's called is In God We
Trust that's the name of study guy
talking about the Bible and finances the
number to call is eight hundred eight
three five six seven four seven you can
ask the study guide call called in god
we trust' and also read their for free
online at the amazing facts website just
amazing facts dot o-r-g
Alex Cooley is Christopher listening in
San Francisco Christopher welcome to the
program you on the air
thank you for having me guys I really
appreciate it thank you yeah I got a
couple of questions number one is how do
we know we have the Holy Spirit what
does
me being so young in Christ all right
well first of all you if you've come to
the Lord and you surrendered to him and
have you made a decision to and you've
been baptized
yeah I have um let me go to a verse
Peter said repent and be baptized by the
way this is Acts chapter two and pastor
Ross I forget the verse number it might
be thirty three he said repent and be
baptized and you'll receive the gift of
the Holy Spirit for the promises unto
you and your children and as many as the
Lord will call and then when Jesus was
baptized the Holy Spirit came down on
him in a special way and
Jesus said go teach baptize in the name
of the Father Son and Holy Spirit it
connects then baptism with the spirit
again also yeah that's Acts chapter two
verse 38 38 so
yeah so there's a promise made that you
may not feel a buzzing and electricity
go up and down your spine when you get
baptized and let me explain the Holy
Spirit he's a person he comes into your
life before you're even a Christian to
lead you to Christ the Holy Spirit comes
and he convicts you of your sin that's
not because he doesn't love you it's
because God does love you and he
impresses you that you need to repent
for your sins and when you do he can be
the same one who brings you power he
brings you peace in
Revelation the Holy Spirit is depicted
as
seven candlesticks a lamb with seven
eyes and talks about the seven spirits
of God be the work and the facets of the
holy spirit are multiple their manifold
and
so the Holy Spirit leads you he comforts
he convicts he's been powers the Spirit
of God came on David and he sing Spirit
of God came on Sampson and he slew snow
it was the same holy spirit so you may
not always feel God's Spirit with you
but if you're continuing to humble
yourself and empty yourself
God's Spirit will fill you
okay thank you
okay
now before I forget though I want to
tell you Chris I've got a a book I'll
send you after your call make sure you
can read it for free or ask for it and
it talks about the Holy Spirit and how
to receive the Holy Spirit so just
remember that your next question okay my
next question was
spiritual tongues I go to church and the
pastor told me just exercise them it's
healthy to exercise so I exercised them
and sometimes I feel that I just want to
don't let them out you know what I mean
and when I do let them out I feel like
you know people looking at me weird
so you're talking about speaking in
tongues yeah and so the pastor is
encouraging you to just when you feel an
impulse to let out some ecstatic
utterance oh yeah all right even more
important than the book I just mentioned
I've got a book we're gonna bring your
volume down a little bit because there's
a beeping I've got a book I've written
and it's called understanding tongues
now Christopher we believe in all the
gifts of the Spirit but the gift of
tongues is often misunderstood you don't
see anywhere in the Bible where Jesus
the Apostles were encouraged or they
encouraged others to just blurt out
ecstatic utterances
at Pentecost when they were filled with
the Holy Spirit and they spoke other
tongues everybody listening from other
countries understood what they were
saying they were speaking in tongues
that had formerly been unknown to them
but they were known to somebody and it
says there were 16 different language
groups so the purpose of the gift of
tongues is you might communicate the
gospel in languages maybe you had not
formally known or studied and not
everybody has the gift of tongues Paul
says in two different books some are
apostles some prophets some are not you
know so some get different gifts that
the Holy Spirit distributes to different
believers different gifts so the idea
that every believer is supposed to speak
in tongues is not biblical
are you still there Chris yeah I'm here
so I hope you'll study that carefully
because you know I know there's a lot of
lovely people that love the Lord that
may believe differently but the gifts of
the Spirit including the gift of tongues
when God lists the gifts tongues is is
one of the lowest gifts some churches
make it one of the most important gifts
and I think we need to keep it in a
biblical balance the Bible says do not
speak in tongues if there's nobody to
translate and that's 1st Corinthians 14
and he also says that I'd rather speak
five words with my understanding that I
might instruct others than 10,000 and
then unknown tongue so he God wants us
to give a certain sound Paul says if the
trumpet gives an uncertain sound if
there's no distinction in the sound
nobody knows what song the trumpeters
playing or how to prepare for battle so
he's saying when you speak speak so
somebody listening understands and
me go ahead pastor Osteen I just want to
mention that book before we forget it's
called understanding tongues a very
important subject and we'll be happy to
send this to you Christopher I hope
you'll call and ask for it the book
again is called understanding tongues
will be happy to send it to you free the
number is 883 five six seven four seven
and asked for the book called
understanding tongues
next caller is
let's see listening from California we
have
aleem oh I guess you need more welcome
to the program
Emilio Emilio all right Thank You Amelia
we've got about 45 seconds
can we do a quick question yes so I'm
calling from Nevada California my
question is in Genesis one three through
five and
one 14 and 15 which says in God say let
there be light and there was light and
God was saw that light that was good and
God divided the light from the darkness
it talks about light and darkness
quickly he
then later on it says God created the
Sun the moon and the stars okay quick
answer to that God was the light in the
beginning it says God is light in him is
no darkness at all so the first light
you see in Genesis is God's presence the
Sun was made on the fourth day
vegetation made on the third day so
these must have been a literal days
sorry to rush you off the air Emilio
thank you for calling friends God
willing we'll be back next week
thank you for listening to today's
broadcast
we hope you understand your Bible even
better than before Bible answers live is
produced by amazing facts a faith-based
ministry located in Sacramento
California
amazing facts through your faithful
support has had a major impact on some
of the largest non-christian locations
in the world beyond the Great Wall the
printing and translation of our books
and video materials are in constant
motion
southeast Ohio faith oxygen tisha
Juliana China - the amazing facts
Chinese language website is now one of
our most visited websites we also
translated thousands of pieces of
literature for these nations what
started out as hundreds of followers is
now in the hundreds of thousands the
impact of your funds invested in sharing
the everlasting gospel in these foreign
lands will be felt for years to come you
know every week we hear the most
incredible stories from all over the
globe of lives that are being changed
and hearts that are being transformed by
the power of the word and none of it
could happen without your teamwork with
this ministry god bless you I
really wanted to start a new devotional
habit but lights got in the way next
thing I know we're a month into the new
year and I'm like what's the point of
starting then I saw 365 amazing answers
to big Bible questions each day is a
single study so you can start anywhere
on any day and not miss a thing their
crisp clear and enlightening
get yours today by calling
[Music]
if you'd like to enhance your study of
God's Word visit our website at WWE
and sign up for our free Bible study
course and make sure to check out our
online bookstore at AF bookstore com
which offers thousands of inspiring
books DVDs and more to help you get the
most out of God's Word to take advantage
of the offers you've heard on this
broadcast call us at
$887
RG did you enjoy this program make sure
to tell your family and friends tune in
next time for more Bible answers live
honest and accurate answers to your
Bible questions
[Music]